comienzo preguntándoles quién conoce a
paris hilton
si está bien que esta mujer vivió varios
años en su infancia pensando en que todo
el mundo era millonario como ella que
teníamos cadenas de hoteles vehículos y
mucho dinero hasta que salió la realidad
en cuenta que no era así parece ridículo
pero en un momento les voy a demostrar
que todos en el momento estamos haciendo
lo mismo que pareciendo
quien de aquí desayuno y bueno no hace
falta que me digan que solo desayuna si
no quiere consumido en la última semana
por lo menos una foto y una verdura
bueno alta en la mano por favor
todos lo que recomiendan otra cosa es
que comamos pues por lo menos las cinco
porciones de fruta y nutrición sin
embargo pues es muy sabido que para que
nosotros tengamos una sana alimentación
debemos incluirlos
no
es maravilloso tiene que vivir lo que
significa respirar lo que significa
[Música]
en plata
tenemos infinidad de caminos
[Música]
d
en la ciudad la verdad es que nunca
había ido al campus se había ido pero el
tipo turista nunca había estado pues a
lo mejor unas cuantas horas y visto sus
modos de vida y todo esto entonces me
puse a cuestas en contra de la historia
y muchas otras en el museo de la
historia mexicana en montaña
bueno
personas derramando sangre para las
tierras que hoy tienen la imagen que se
observa aquí
la primera imagen no sé si se logra ver
pero son cajas de ataúd con campesinos
muertos
estas personas fueron despojados de sus
tierras en la época hacendaria entonces
para lograr que se le respeten sus
derechos hubo mucha sangre hubo mucha
guerra son personas que fueron
despojadas y muchas otras que no tenían
tierras y se les fueron se les soltaron
por medio de la reforma agraria que
bueno no nos gusten pueden consultar la
historia muy interesante por cierto
y bueno a vivir en estas personitas que
muchas de ellas son de poblaciones
indígenas
mis temas se llama el pecado de nacer
mujer en el campo
todos sabemos aquí lo difícil que es ser
mujer
en la ciudad también sabemos lo difícil
que es ser un campesino
junto en esas dos situaciones
en el campo de verdad por eso el bus es
pecado porque parece que tienen una
penitencia de por vida ya por el hecho
de nacer y les voy a platicar por qué
en este momento les voy a pedir a todos
los que están en este momento viéndome
escuchándome
que cierren los ojos
y que se olviden de todo el disco y el
chip que tienen en su vida en este
momento no se llaman como se llaman no
son ustedes en este momento van a nacer
van a ser partidos pueden abrir en este
momento los ojos
y ustedes no saben nada del mundo no
conocen derechos no conocen sueños nada
lo único que saben es que han abierto
los ojos y tienen un padre que está
rechazando las porque además déjenme
decirles nacen mujeres si son hombres
imagínense que nacen mujeres
entonces su padre pelea lado está
rechazando porque el macho camacho y
bueno esas ideas de repente vienen sin
generalizar obviamente pero las personas
no no siempre son muy cuerdas y dicen
que macho la madre pues si es una mujer
es algo negativo entonces de ahí ya
apenas acaban de abrir los ojos y ya
tienen un estigma y en la frente no
ahora
ustedes vienen en esta familia rural
recursos bajos entonces por suerte
tienen un padre de una madre que los
quiere vamos a poner la vida de una
campesina con suerte imagínense y
después de que también luchar la lo que
es la vida de la campesina consorte
bueno sus padres los quieren entonces
resulta ser que les dicen bueno vamos a
meter a la escuela y rompen el esquema
de que las mujeres tienen que dedicarse
a la familia y enseñarles a hacer
quehaceres a lavar trastes porque eso es
lo que tengo entonces ustedes por suerte
fuera pueden ir a la escuela sin embargo
les pérez multigrado para que no sepan
qué es eso es que del primer año de
primaria sexto esté en una sola aula con
un solo maestro a cargo que muchas veces
es el director también el intendente y
el encargado de absolutamente todo
entonces imagínense el reto increíble
que tienen esos maestros encargados de
toda la educación de la población a
nivel primaria donde a los niños de seis
años les tienen que enseñar a leer y
escribir pero los niños que van saliendo
de sexuales tienen que dar las
competencias necesarias para pasar un
examen de admisión para el siguiente
nivel educativo
dijimos que eran sordas entonces paso en
el siguiente nivel pasan a la secundaria
porque son muy capaces del hecho todas
las ganas del mundo tuvieron mucha
suerte
después llega la opinión de la familia y
de la realidad donde ustedes ya tienen
fuerza de trabajo y la familia dice
bueno qué hacemos para nuestra educación
o gómez literalmente esa es la postura
de la gente no como o me educó
evidentemente tienen que sobrevivir
entonces trabajan
no sé si se van hay pueblos donde las
únicas fuentes de trabajo cercanas
porque las distancias tan horribles son
máquinas por ejemplo donde los salarios
son de mil pesos y tienen que trabajar
de lunes a sábado 13 horas esas son las
condiciones de una mujer muchos menos en
el campo que nosotros no sabemos que
existen ahora como decimos que son por
dudas sus papás les lleva un permiso y
por donde no se las robaron porque
además se las pueden robar en este
proceso porque algún chavo le desagrada
y quiere robarse la par casarse con
ustedes no todo entonces la robaron
pudieron ir al escuela están trabajando
porque hay un chance de trabajar y ser
independientes pero un día de estos
salen del trabajo y
resulta ser que los pueblos no siempre
tienen toda la seguridad y la luz
eléctrica que se necesita como nosotros
conseguimos como algo natural aquí en la
ciudad entonces en camino a casa ya muy
noche porque trabajaron 13 horas muy
arduas en sobre un atentado de violación
digo antes ya les habían robado cosas no
lo mejor su salario no lo sé pero sufren
sufren un atentado de velación y como
son fortunas no las violaron entonces
deciden irse a la ciudad dicen no eso no
es para mí este quiero tocar nuevas
puertas que no saben qué va a pasar
conmigo quiero crecer porque se dan
cuenta que en su pero no en la zona
rural donde nadie pone atención es
difícil que lleguen a tener en esta
oportunidad es
bueno se les dificulta además porque a
lo mejor ni siquiera la en español
tienen lenguas diferentes del español
entonces solamente imagínense a lo que
se tienen que enfrentar
después va a ver toda esta realidad la
vez que no pude dormir me puse a
investigar qué sucede con estas mujeres
y dije cómo es posible que estamos como
paris hilton que creemos que como
estamos en nuestra ficción nuestra
burbuja de la ciudad donde tenemos todo
a la mano creemos que todo el mundo lo
tiene la mano no es así
como no sucede en carne propia
empatizamos no hacemos nada donde pueda
investigar sobre los derechos agrarios y
descubrí que para las mujeres existen
aquí se tanto una parte el dato
importante en 1901 es decir hace 47 años
en materia agraria la mujer existe antes
no existía y enseñarle sus abuelas no
podían tener tierras no podían montar no
existían jurídicamente han existido
entonces imagínense lo que hace eso en
1992 viene un programa para adoptar para
reconocer las tierras a las personas del
campo y para 1993 se hacen estudios y
solamente el 16 por ciento de las
tierras y de los derechos son para
mujeres sólo el 16 por ciento para 2017
que prácticamente pasó la edad que yo
tengo
se duplicó este porcentaje se duplicó al
menos de 35 por ciento solamente estoy
hablando de los derechos y me emocioné
dije guau mi padre la verdad es que se
duplicó eso significa que estamos
avanzando
pero las letras chiquitas solamente de
ese 35 por ciento solamente dónde está
nada positiva menos del 3% adquieres
derechos por medios propias quiere decir
que las demás mujeres adquirieron los
derechos porque se murió el papá porque
por que enviudaron por qué
heredaron cualquier situaciones de éstas
donde el hombre no existió y pues como
unimos al quedar a nadie se le queda la
mujer porque además hay mucha migración
en los hombres como decía bien este
litoral
entonces bueno es triste es de tres me
alarmó menos del 3%
ese 3% concierto estamos hablando de
hace apenas un año no estamos hablando
de los años cincuentas entonces dije
bueno esta práctica es del
empoderamiento femenino estamos de
acuerdo entonces qué pasa con las
mujeres no hay muchas personas que sean
nuevo pues para que ramos de temas de
género no es necesario porque ya lo
somos y la mujer somos iguales sí porque
vivimos en nuestra ficción y nuestra
burbuja evidentemente aquí así es que en
padre y lo aplaudo y ojalá si fueran
para todos pero no lo es entonces
investigue y nosotros acerca de la
representación femenina cada pueblo debe
entender porque nos de representación
tienen tres sujetos en el comisariado y
tres en el de vigilancia de temas
jurídicos sin embargo les comentó que
actualmente hasta hace un año el 90%
eran hombres
ahí hay un error las mujeres solamente
son el 10% y para colmo el líder de la
población que es el presidente del
comisariado las mujeres representan sólo
un 2% entonces yo me pregunto qué está
la equidad de género
y esto considerando que para el año para
diciembre de 2016
se hizo una adición al artículo 37 de la
ley agraria donde se está obligando
gracias al cielo se está obligando a que
los órganos de representación tengan una
50 por ciento de personas del mismo
género esto quiere decir que es una
obligación que hay un 40 por ciento para
2020 que va a ser cuando todos los
órganos de representación cada uno
tengan que hacerse sí o sí tendrá que
estar ese 40 por ciento pero qué pasa en
la realidad en la realidad lo que sucede
es que bueno como les platiqué tuve una
oportunidad de tener contacto con cerca
de 200 poblaciones lo que se representa
con poco más de 500 representantes
agrarios en el estado
y cada que veo una mujer la pierde
armonía chinita y me emocionaba ese agua
o solamente venía de como 500
aproximadamente
y es así es solamente dos estaban
realmente empoderadas eran líderes
y me emocioné obviamente pero las demás
me hacía reclamos lecciones que sabes
que de camino se pusieron para rellenar
la planilla para cumplir el requisito no
me toman en cuenta me dejan afuera
entonces es triste de darse cuenta que
nosotros pensamos aquí en la ciudad que
como hemos hecho nuestro no pasa nada y
luego vemos mujeres que vienen del campo
en nuestra ciudad y quieren soñar
siquiera tener un sueño porque en el
campo la verdad es que las mujeres ni
siquiera saben que pueden soñar
y nosotros las discriminamos o decimos
acá es esta mujer acá me va a pedir
comida me pitaron cual cosa entonces hay
que ser un poco empáticos les vuelve a
picar que es lo que podemos hacer con un
reto muy breve la semana pasada
precisamente fui a una población y
requería de la opinión de unas mujeres
ya que los han prestado hablar conmigo
porque pasé a la mujer entonces les dije
a las mujeres tenido por sus niños al
kinder que son estas niñas por cierto
con carmen geniales y hermosas que les
dispara un futuro y que están y que se
escuchan como yo les pido la opinión
y sus madres me dicen después de varias
preguntas y de atreverse a alzar la
mirada le dicen sabes que yo soy mujer
somos mujeres no nos vemos a nosotros
porque nosotros no tenemos voto ellas en
realidad creen que son parte del
patrimonio del hombre que son un
instrumento o un mueble más que no
tienen voz ni voto porque se los han
dicho que se los han hecho creer hay
otras poblaciones donde las mujeres no
se pueden sentar en la silla se sienten
en la parte de atrás ya que en las
sillas sentados en frente van los
hombres y las mujeres valen el psoe la
otras entonces son situaciones muy
graves donde solamente me va a estar con
mis ideas a las mujeres dos frases muy
sencillas siles a mí no me interesa si
son hombres o mujeres
ambos valen exactamente igual con esas
cosas que yo les dije que cualquiera de
ustedes puede decir estas mujeres hice
un cambio de chip
tuvieron unos minutos de reflexión ya
sabes que yo soy quiero opinar pero no
podemos superar muchos obstáculos y no
somos para que a victimizar vengo a
decirles que han sido reprimidas e
ignoradas invisibilizadas entonces la
pregunta es
ahora que tú ya sabes todo lo que lo que
pasa en el campo fuera de tu ficción y
por paris hilton porque mucha gente se
rió de esta situación
porque vas a hacerlo gracias
[Aplausos]